تجدد للحرب وانتقال من طور الدفاع الى
الهجوم توقعات بتصعيد الحرب الاوكرانيه
بدات بعد ان تحولت للمساعدات الغربيه
لاوكرانيا الى الاسلحه الثقيله اخرها
مدفعيه بعيده المدى وصواريخه يصل مداها
الى 150 كيلومترا ومدرعات مسلحه تقدمها
واشنطن وقبل ذلك دبابات غربيه
ان المساعده تشتمل خصوصا على قدرات الدفاع
جوي حاسمه لمساعده اوكرانيا في الدفاع عن
سكانها وذخيره لرجمات صواريخه مارس
المدفعيه الجديده التي ستضاعف مدى وصول
الذخائر تاتي في اطار مساعده بقيمه
مليارين و 200 مليون دولار تتضمن ايضا
صواريخ بعيده المدى عاليه الدقه بالاضافه
لقنابل جي ال اس دي بي محموله على صواريخك
[موسيقى]
اسلحه لطالما تمنعت الولايات المتحده من
ارسالها لاوكرانيا خوفا من ان تستهدف
الاخيره الاراضي الروسيه وهو ما يخمنه
الخبراء العسكريون الان حيث حذر مجلس
الامن الروسي مع وصول هذه الاسلحه من ان
اي استهداف للاراضي الروسيه سيكون الرد
عليه بحرق اوكرانيا وان الحرب ستتوسع
لتكون عالميه وعمر العربيه